qu'est ce que la bolivie c'est un pays
dont la plus grande ville la base est à
4000 mètres d'altitude
c'est le pays des mines d'étain des
incas du pétrole de la jungle c'est
aussi celui d'une population d'environ 5
millions d'habitants dont 70% ne
participent pas à la vie économique
ce sont les indiens et les paysans le
petit pour les tares dia qui se
contentent de subsister c'est pour eux
que le che avait entrepris sa lutte
le régime précédent la fit assassiner et
à emprisonner régis debray un avion
militaire nous a déposés à camiri à midi
le jour de noël dans une chaleur
tropicale cameri c'est tout à l'extrême
sud de la bolivie près de l'équateur
c'est là que che guevara a été exécuté
c'est là que régis debray a été arrêté
le 19 avril 1967 alors qu'il quittait
précisément le maquis de che guevara
c'est là qu'a eu lieu son procès en
novembre 1967
c'est là qu'il a été condamné à 30 ans
de prison c'est là qu'il passe ses
journées
comment se passe aujourd'hui ici
écoutez c'est pas ici qu'elle sait pas
dans votre ampli ça dans ma cellule qui
est la voix mais bien le se passe dans
une pièce qui est petit site qui à deux
mètres sur trois et où il ne se passait
rien
par définition puisque si je vous
demandais ce que c'est et physiquement
très dure
non je crois que vraiment actuellement
il faut s'occuper des prisonniers au
brésil faut pas s'occuper de moi parce
que je crois que les fêtes cette
campagne qu'il ya eu a amené une
amélioration des commissions détention
un mois ou deux et vraiment je pense oui
ces campagnes en france oui ces
campagnes en france et ailleurs ici même
en bolivie où un mouvement de solidarité
très remarquable
les étudiants des ouvriers et je crois
que c'est plutôt qu'à marins de torture
et du brier il faut penser moi je vais
dans une cellule du matin au soir et du
soir au matin et pis c'est tout là rien
à dire depuis il me suivait ce qui se
passe quand même à l'extérieur
oui je reçois les journaux bolivien la
plupart du temps en tout cas je les
nouvelles que les américains veulent
bien donner puisque ce sont ces
nouvelles qu'ils sont publiées par les
journaux locaux
que pensez-vous des événements qui se
sont passés en france depuis que vous
êtes sentent raison est vraiment du
départ du v12 beige
alors ça c'est une question vraiment
complète que à laquelle je ne peux pas
répondre en trois mots c'est une
question très difficile
vous pensez que c'est une chose
importante bien sûr que c'est très
important
tout ce que je souhaite c'est que les
packs avec le général de gaulle dans la
voie d'une politique indépendante de
moeurs et subsiste inchangé c'est tout
ce que je souhaite pour vous le problème
de votre libération ne semble donc pas
se poser comme celui simplement de votre
individus bien sûr que non ne serait ce
que pour une raison très simple c'est
que le jour où sortir d'ici il faudra
que tous les autres pays amis soient
déjà sorti et on n'est plus considéré
comme un délinquant de droit commun et
que général au 23 dit je crois pour la
première fois depuis très longtemps dans
ce pays qu'il n'y avait pas à donner
d'industeel 25 décembre par tout
simplement parce qu'il avait pas de
prisonniers politiques
il sait bien c'est faux mais il sait
bien pourquoi il doit le dire il doit le
dire parce que là des formes très
puissante à l'intérieur du pays et à
l'extérieur mais il a dit qu'il était
favorable à une révision d'autres procès
qui serait déjà un pas vers la liberté
est une blague pour enfant de trois ans
le procès n'est pas révisable il a déjà
été confirmée en appel par le tribunal
militaire supérieur il n'y a aucune
possibilité de révision quand ça il a
inventé cette fausse fenêtre pour
trouver une attitude
mais ce n'est pas ni juridiquement
possible ni politiquement souhaitable
quand je n'ai aucune intention de
demander la révision de ce procès qui
est un fait politique qui doit être
considérée sous un angle uniquement
politique c'est à dire sous l'angle de
la mystique politique dans la mesure où
ces moyens qui est donné aux gouvernants
des pays dans lesquels il se produit des
changements politiques ici je crois
qu'ils aient produit un changement
politique
il ya six mois c'est un changement
encore très contradictoires très
instable très confus
et jusqu'à ce que les choses se définit
je ne sortirai pas si vous sortiez petit
temps que ce pays aura des rapports avec
l'impérialisme américain rapports qui
subsiste en profondeur et la fraction la
plus réactionnaire de l'armée qui me
maintient ici c'est parfaitement ce
qu'elle ferme maintenant en prison
puisque au prochain coup d'état ils
auront l'occasion de régler le problème
certainement de manière plus définitive
en sorte que ma situation est ouverte à
toutes les
toutes les surprises vous avez dit à la
fin de votre procès je suis coupable de
croire à la victoire finale et prochaine
du che est ce que vous êtes toujours de
cet avis bien entendu pour distinguer
entre une forme maman tenait qu'a revêtu
la lune tu te fais est une inspiration
est essentielle l'inspiration
ce qui n'est pas n'est pas réductible à
une seule forme de lutte inspiration
d'ordre historique et le sel
je crois de tous les peuples d'amérique
latine
promenez-vous n'importe où vous verrez
le portrait du che que ce soit chez les
étudiants on sait les surveiller le
gabaye c'était une erreur d'entreprendre
ce qu'il a entrepris en bolivie non
après c'est facile à dire avant c'est
beaucoup plus difficile
les militants n'ont pas ces recours de
pouvoir se justifier ou dénoncer les
erreurs une fois qu'elles ont été
commises
les militants sont des gens qu'ils se
risquent toujours un peu et et qui
payent pour les risques qui traînent les
gèle ses camarades dont impayés beaucoup
moi je portais ce que je voudrais dire
justement c'est que nous voyons là dans
un cadre ma foi assez agréable il fait
beau il ya du soleil est passé militaire
ce serait pour le mieux mais votre
cellule et aux différentes menaces et on
m'amène jamais ici c'est la première
fois que je viens ici plutôt la deuxième
fois que je viens ici et comment les
votes aux cellules basées elle est toute
petite elle est entouré de fils de fer
barbelés miradors et loin des 6 de
landreau nous sommes non sans mettre
peut-être 50 m c'est une toute petite
prison c'est une prison comme une sorte
depuis la fosse aux ours où on sort pour
les entrevues depuis qu'il y à des
entrevues site ou même un fait positif
vous le voyez vous voyez traitement on
en dehors de votre femme qui a
maintenant une autorisation spéciale
elle a une autorisation pour rester 15
jours ici c'est vraiment formidable mais
je crois que c'est non merci
c'est le résultat je crois que tu mets
ta non jeunes fumer des cigares mais non
merci
c'est le mot jazz gracias le résultat je
crois que solidarité qui lie
autant il ya six mois mais conditions
j'ai pas de feu n'ont autant il ya six
mois mais comme d'un gilet l'on sente
améliorée depuis
depuis deux mois vous n'ai pas
l'impression qu'avec ces améliorations
enfin surtout le permission accordée à
votre femme et les autres améliorations
relatives vous ai parlé
on se suit quand même vers le nouveau
régime bolivien eux semblent vouloir
vous libérer un jour ou l'autre
comme les titres des journaux récemment
disait que le président 22 n'était pas
contre une libération qu'il fallait
réviser le procès président au 22e temps
est au centre d'un dispositif où il ya
une aile droite et une aile gauche
l'ailé gauche et révolutionnaire
évidemment ne peux pas concevoir que les
révolutionnaires prisonniers dans ce
pays l'ailé droite et contre
révolutionnaires et à jeter dans la
balance toute sa puissance pour que je
ne sorte pas d'ici tant que cette
contradiction ne soit pas résolu je ne
sortirai pas aux revendeurs ne peut pas
faire plus que que les forces sur
lesquelles ils s'appuient je prends plus
comment d'autres sans doute quelqu'un
qui ait évolué depuis
il signe là une évolution politique
intellectuel indubitable pays cherche
l'appui du peuple
il l'a presque trouvé pas tout à fait
encore pour qui le trouvera encore qu'il
fasse quelques petits pas est ce que
vous voulez que le gouvernement français
que vos amis français continue l'action
qu'ils ont entreprises en votre faveur
qu'il accentue que faut-il faire parce
que parfois on a l'impression que le
gouvernement bolivien est plus les
terres et agacé on ne sait pas
exactement
c'est une question délicate le
gouvernement français
je me suis très reconnaissant et tout ce
qu'il a fait mais il est évident qu'on
ne peut pas faire plus pour beaucoup de
raisons quant à mes amis français je
crois aussi plus en fait tout ce qu'ils
ont pu
je crois qu'on ne peut pas encore
définir ce qu'il faut faire
cette embolie vite la fosse se passe en
amérique de celui c'est pas en france
en un sens un peu latino américain et le
trouvant dans un pays latino américains
il est normal que les forces qui m'a
puisqu à de ces pays mène cela dit ce
que les amis et ceux qui ne sont pas des
amis
ces personnes que je ne connais pas un
fait en france est vraiment émouvant
pour moi remarquable et qu'au fond ils
en ont déjà beaucoup fait presque trop
fait et je ne suis vraiment pas disposés
à leur en demander plus il faudrait
vraiment manqué de tout une élémentaire
modestie c'est déjà énorme ce qui s'est
passé je crois que je crois que c est
faux il faut poursuivi il faut il faut
me faire revenir à l'anonymat du club
n'aurait dû jamais sortir je crois qu'on
a beaucoup trop parlé de la faire de
vrais manière générale c'est un peu un
peu peut-être à considérer de dire ça
parce que ça m'a aidé et finalement je
dire dans ce moment difficile mais je
persiste à penser que je ne mérite pas
tous tout ce bruit
toute cette campagne tout est dans la
norme qui est là condamné à 30 ans de
prison où il y en a tellement d'autres
elle a tellement d'autres mais
personnellement je persiste à penser
qu'on en a beaucoup trop fait pour moi
et que vraiment je ne mérite pas que
c'est noël aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
avez passé noël d'une façon particulière
non
on va dire j'y pense parce que vous êtes
là en fait les jours se ressemblent aux
vous il n'y a pas de changement c'est
pour moi le changement c'est de vous
voir aujourd'hui et c'est formidable
c'est surprenant feu doit voler
aujourd'hui noël pour moi est un jour
comme un autre sauf que ma femme est là
et plein de visiter cet après midi et
tout le temps que nous vous prenons
maintenant nous l'enlevons à votre femme
au jeu c'est pas honteux que tu as
peut-être une compensation on donnera à
18 de plus c'est pas je vous remercie